you probably know that where this is
going because I told you I'm a big fan
of horror I love werewolf by night and I
love the idea of Marvel embracing horror
more
I don't know I'm sure you can't tell us
anything about the continuation of that
character in the franchise but I was
curious about your opinion on
maintaining that tone and that style and
that grasp on that genre but if he were
to move into another corner of that
franchise do you think there's a way to
continue the character but still
maintain what makes werewolf by night so
unique oh cool I thought that you were
gonna for a moment I thought that you
were going to mention how Cassandra is
going to incorporate into the horror
world of Marvel and that would have been
like what yeah I mean I'd be fun
exactly yeah of course I would be
delighted because also it was just a
little tease what I what we got you know
and what I experienced by by playing
this character in werewolf finite I
loved it I I and and the people that
were there you know with Laura Donnelly
I mean it was fantastic to work with her
because she's a very strong die die hard
horror movie fan you know and uh and it
was fantastic play that and yes I hope
that we can do that in in different ways
shapes and forms and that uh and who
knows where it's going to go I have no
idea but I'm really I'm I'm I want to be
part of that and uh and I really love
the the how it came out uh yeah I'm very
pleased I love horror movies as well I'm
not a big fan because I get really
scared
um but uh but I like them a lot I I
think it's the most uh yeah it is like
the one of the the it is the genre that
income that encompasses the best aspects
of filmmaking you know it is like Opera
in a way I love it I love it